leute fragen sich auch immer was dieses
ebook proksa ist genau dasselbe habe ich
mich auch gefragt was zur hölle ist ebay
profis eben was hilft und vor allem wo
zur hölle bekomme ich diese das werde
ich in dieser woche gemeinsam mit euch
herausfinden viel spaß nicht völlig habe
ihre prozent
[Musik]
also tatsächlich kam mir die idee über
profactor herzustellen eigentlich gar
nicht durch ron und nico sondern durch
ein problem das ich hatte führt dass ich
mit einem medikament eine lösung gesucht
habe der ein oder andere von euch kennt
es vielleicht ihr habt so viel getrunken
und ihr probiert in irgendeiner weise
vorzusorgen dass der karte nicht so
schlimm geht ein ganz bestimmtes produkt
dominiert den markt und scheint dabei
abhilfe zu schaffen elo trans das ganze
ist ein elektrolyt mischung die man nach
dem trinken vorm schlafengehen mit
wasser mischt und dann trinkt das soll
quasi den kater mindern oder sogar
komplett eliminieren es gibt da jetzt
allerdings ein problem für mich ist
schmeckt so unglaublich ekelhafte das
ist tatsächlich nicht runter bekommen
ich weiß dass die wirkung gut ist aber
ich kriege es einfach nicht runter
außerdem habe ich mich gefragt gibt es
eine möglichkeit die trans höher zu
dosieren also eine elektrolyt mischung
zusammen zu mixen die noch besser
funktioniert als elo trans und
gleichzeitig gut schmeckt oder noch gar
nicht schmeckt so dass es sich anfühlt
als würde man einfach ein liter wasser
trinken und der kater am nächsten morgen
ist weg ach ja und ich bin
offensichtlich nicht der einzige der an
elo trans und seine wirkung glaubt dass
hier sind ein paar der amazon bewertung
wer kennt es nicht der kumpel kommt auf
ein bier vorbei zwei gehen schon und
dann sind schon drei und schwupps hat
man dem weihnachtsmann fulminant den
schlitten gewachst ich weiß nicht was
das heißen soll aber wir lesen weiter
wenn ihr also nächstes mal dem räuber
hotzenplotz die einfahrt kirchers da
lieber mit diesem pulver nacharbeiten es
spart euch einiges an körperlichen
ethanol ogen gebrechen ok und man ist
schneller wieder bereit dem
schneewittchen die gaube zu verhindern
zittrige hände schrems und kalt weiß das
ist alles mit diesem hübschen geschichte
all die menschen in welche richtung das
geht von diesen kommentaren gibt es noch
eine menge weitere die geister 2 kanal
von simplicissimus dafür mit ihren video
komplett nur über diese kommentare ist
der video beschreibung verlinkt ach ja
und auch abseits des haufens bin ich
absolut überzeugt von elektrolyt
mischung wir haben sie auf der
besteigung des 4.000 auf dem weg nach
paris ist und bei ganz vielen anderen
situation benutzt sogar im alltag trinkt
ich hier und da elektrolyte weil ich das
gefühl habe ich zu meinem körper
irgendwie was gutes damit und wenn wir
sie erschaffen das hört zu dosieren und
vielleicht noch andere sachen mit
hinzuzufügen also irgendwelche vitamine
wie der körper braucht die man
vielleicht im winter zu wenig bekommt
dann könnte es tatsächlich ein wirklich
gutes produkt werden dass wir im alltag
nutzen können und jetzt heißt es für uns
folgendes zu tun natürlich vorrangig das
produkt entwickeln das produkt muss
funktionieren im besten fall besser
funktionieren als elo trans gleichzeitig
muss es gut schmecken oder im besten
fall noch gar nicht schmecken also
wirklich ein produkt entwickeln das
besser ist als das was es gibt im
zweiten schritt würde man sich
umverpackung design und das komplette
drumherum kümmern muss vermutlich auch
website und auch eine marketingstrategie
wenn das jetzt wirklich alles gut
funktionieren würde dann werde man
vermutlich so weit dass man probiert
einen lohn hersteller zu finden der
dieses produkt wirklich für einen
produzieren wir starten aber bei punkt
eins der produktion einer perfekten
elektrolyt mischung ja also ich habe
tatsächlich vor elektrolyt mischung
anfertigen zu lassen und ich habe mich
gefragt ob es noch apotheken gibt die
sowas selber selber zusammen mischen
können
okay und mein ziel wäre es die die
mischung höher zu dosieren ist es
möglich bei ihnen auch geschmacksstoffe
hinzufügen zu lassen
super aber ich danke vielmals schönen
tag noch also scheinbar habe ich eine
apotheke gefunden die das alles für mich
machen kann jetzt müssen wir nur hoffen
dass die alle anteile natriumchlorid
kaliumchlorid atrium zieht zwei wasser
und glucose da haben damit wir das
vernünftig zusammen mischen können sie
probiert die anteile zu erhöhen um quasi
eine höhere dosierung zu haben sie guckt
ob die geschmacksstoffe hat die wir
entweder hinzufügen können oder denen
geschmack komplett weg zu neutralisieren
also es scheint ziemlich gut zu laufen
jetzt frage ich noch dazu ob wir bei dem
zusammen mischen dabei sein können und
dann perfekt beim zusammenmischen dabei
sein hat leider nicht funktioniert aber
tatsächlich haben wir jetzt das fertige
produkt und so sieht es aus
[Musik]
höher dosiert ob da jetzt insgesamt mehr
drin ist oder die konzentration wirklich
höher ist das weiß es nicht aber
anscheinend soll es mehr knallt außerdem
habe ich vitamin c noch hinzufügen
lassen vitamin d habe ich dann in
flüssiger form noch mitgebracht um es
einfach selber noch hinzuzufügen das
bedeutet wir haben ein höher dosiert
dass electronic gemisch mit vitamin also
genau das was wir wollten aber wir haben
leider keine geschmacksstoffe mit drin
die den geschmack in irgendeiner weise
übertünchen oder neutralisieren können
weil die apotheke das einfach nicht
vorrätig hatte deswegen bin ich einfach
in normalen einkaufsladen gefahren und
habe völlig normale geschmacksstoffe
gekauft die ich dann dazu gemischt habe
um auszuprobieren ob es besser wird oder
nicht bevor wir jetzt aber gemeinsam
testen ob es wirklich funktioniert wie
gut es funktioniert und vor allem wie es
schmeckt müssen uns erst mal überlegen
wie wir das ganze produkt darstellen und
mit ganz besonderem augenmerk auf das
packaging die ganzen medikamente kommen
ja ihn so typischen medizin verpackungen
deswegen habe ich photoshop
angeschmissen um genau so eine
verpackung für ihre praxen zu entwickeln
kofax es ist perfekt geworden genau so
habe ich mir das vorgestellt es ist
wirklich einfach so eine medizin
verpacken das einzige was jetzt noch
wichtig ist ist dass die flasche genau
daran hast und dann könnte das wirklich
so in apotheke stehen über praxis pulver
ist ein rein trinken das ist es hier
noch so ein paar angaben da steht
natürlich nix also nur scheiße aber es
sieht sehr gut aus für mich der moment
der wahrheit
das ist perfekt
es wackelt sogar so ein bisschen da drin
liegt wie bei normalen medikamenten das
ist die boku faxe holy shit ein
bisschen wackelig noch ja ja klar als
prototyp ist das wirklich eins aber
genau das ist einfach ein konzept und es
sich kinder halt es sieht wirklich so
aus als könnte ist so eine apotheke
stehen so blau so ganz leichte schrift
das ist eu wachse perfekt und es gibt
nur eine möglichkeit das ganze zu testen
ich trinke mir heute richtig einen reich
[Musik]
ich bin franzose ich haben französischen
ausweis der partie
wenn ich jetzt noch mal fressen das als
randthema
es ist soweit wir waren unterwegs jetzt
kommt es tatsächlich zum test
[Applaus]
sich alles fühlt sich sofort
[Musik]
also gut schmeckt es nicht wir
hoffentlich wird ich bin tatsächlich
nicht der einzige der das heute testet
ich habe es noch kollegen mit gegeben
also heute das war jetzt aber auf jeden
fall der härtetest mehr geht nicht
morgen werden wir wissen ob ihre
prozesse tatsächlich funktioniert
schlafen gehen dann gibt es morgen das
finale das gesund hat
okay meister tag ich merke dass ich
trinken das vor allem aber daran dass
ich so eine rauch stimme habe aber es
funktioniert ich habe keine
kopfschmerzen mehr geht es nicht
schlecht die mopo faxe funktioniert das
ist kein witz und wer hätte das gedacht
vor sieben tagen war das hier nur eine
doofe idee und jetzt haben wir
tatsächlich ein produkt das wirklich
funktioniert hat hat nicht gut
geschmeckt aber es hat funktioniert dann
habe ich zumindest eins der ziele
erreicht es hat wirklich wunderbar
funktioniert ob sie jetzt besser war als
elo trans weiß ich nicht es war auf
jeden fall höher dosiert und ich hatte
keinen kater also alles was wir wollen
vitamin d und vitamin c war auch mit
drin ich habe mich auf jeden fall sehr
gut gefühlt wir haben ihre profis
entwickelt und ibo faxe hat funktioniert
jetzt würde es weitergehen mit man
probiert den geschmack wirklich weg zu
bekommen man sucht ein lohnhersteller
mann daraus ein echtes produkt zu machen
dann bringt man das vielleicht in im
fertigen getränke in pulverform in einer
großen pulver box wie ein gaming booster
das obliegt aber alles nicht mehr die
ebooks auf dieses komplette dingen ist
natürlich nie kos und rhodos mir ging es
nur um dieses video es war lustig diesen
ersten entwicklungsprozess eines
produktes mal zu durchlaufen es könnte
er theoretisch auch sein dass man das
dann wirklich mal ernster angeht und
probiert ein produkt dieses jahr die
beine zu stellen wenn ihr drauf habt
lasst es mich in den kommentaren wissen
vergesst nicht das video zu leiten und
den kanal zu abonnieren dann sehen wir
uns am donnerstag wieder das hat eine
menge spaß gemacht auf ihrer pro fax